here's what would happen if your body  was recycled  to keep your organs young and ready for  use by another human you could use  cenolytic drugs to get rid of old cells  and build new ones the extra body parts  would add to the 14 000 organs donated  yearly in the United States for the 109  000 people on the national transplant  list or you could literally go back to  the Earth  some companies will put you in a vessel  with wood chips Alfalfa and straw  breaking you down with microbes for 30  days to create one cubic yard of  nutrient-rich soil with heat pressure  carbon and 200 grams of cremated remains  you could also become a human Diamond  within six to nine months if you'd  rather be put to Artistic use you could  also mix your ashes with tattoo ink  giving a personal touch pun intended to  some cool tattoos  so